Um, good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you for coming and joining us today.
Appreciate you joining us
instead of going to see
Werner's presentation, obviously we, uh,
we're more exciting than he is. It's true,
it's true,
um. Today
we're going to be talking about Amazon Leo
and how we built this low Earth orbit satellite
system on top of AWS.
I'm Gary.
With me is my, with me is my colleague, Andy.
We'll be taking you through this today.
But before we get started,
I just want to highlight that this is a session
about Amazon on AWS.
Anyone out here familiar with Amazon?
Maybe these are some brands that you're familiar with.
Anyone have a fire TV at home?
Yeah, a little bit of Amazon Music, groceries
delivered from Fresh.
How about watching NFL football on Prime?
Yeah? Alright,
so you're familiar with the kind of work that we do.
What's interesting is, Amazon is
actually treated like any other customer
on AWS.
They don't get a lot of special treatment.
They ask for a lot of special treatment, but they don't
always get it.
Which meant what means is
you as customers of AWS get
all the same benefits as Amazon does.
They utilize the same resources on AWS
that you do. Now you
may do different things with them.
You may not have events like Prime Day.
These are just some data points from this
past summer's Prime Day.
Numbers like
8 8.9 trillion log
events in guard duty.
Big numbers
Candisa streams millions,
1.5 quadrillion
elastic cash requests.
I can vouch that my wife
in her searches on Amazon that day.
At least delivered a million of those.
Now, your services may not
require this type of scale.
But the benefit you get by having Amazon
be a customer on AWS
is they really push the envelope and they force
AWS to push the envelope,
force us to do better, force us to be able
to deliver bigger.
And as a result,
US customers of AWS benefit
from all of this.
Amazon is constantly pushing us
to higher and higher heights.
But today we've gone even higher.
L minus 7 minutes
status check to proceed with terminal count.
Atlas systems propulsion. Go
hydraulics go.
Sorry, there should be audio. Oh, you guys, you
guys can hear the audio. I'm sorry,
go LO 2
LH 2.
And I'm like
striker, you have permission to launch.
Proceeding with the count 321.
Yeah C
We are now moving at 4000 miles an hour.
nominal mechanical proceeding nominally. All
Kuiper satellites have been deployed successfully.
Congrats, Kuiper.
Amazon Leo,
or some of you may recall it being named Kuiper
Project Kuiper.
Now pushing the envelope of the
planet. We are going now
into space, we're building satellite systems,
satellite systems that are bringing reliable
connectivity across the globe
for consumers, businesses and enterprise
and government use cases.
AWS is part of that
process. OK,
that's what we're gonna be talking about today.
So let's look at our agenda. It's actually quite
simple. First
we're gonna talk about how Amazon Leo
built its service using AWS.
Again, I want to reiterate they're using the same AWS
services as all of you have access to.
Second, we want to give you some guidance
on how you can take advantage
of Amazon Leo for your own services.
So you can apply it to your business.
OK. So to get us started,
I'm going to hand over to Andy
to tell you more about how Amazon Leo was built.
Great. Hi folks. Uh, can you hear me?
Great, cool. So, uh, we are
gonna talk about how we build Amazon Leo
on AWS,
and I gotta tell you, building something at the scale of Amazon
Leo is pretty much impossible, and
it's not just one impossible problem, it's like 5
impossible problems
starting from like building at the lowest layer custom
AIs and custom hardware to build a 100
gigabit per second communication satellite
to building a custom e-commerce stack to
run telecommunication services for the world.
This is not a talk about how AWS
solved all those problems for us.
This is a talk about how we use AWS
to not reinvent
the same solutions to commodity problems
that everyone else has already
invented and instead enabling
us to focus on our core business problems.
So let's start with an overview of the Kuiper
system. As you might imagine,
we have some satellites and some ground
stations, and if you zoom like way out from
Kuiper, it looks a lot like
a cell network that you use to connect
to the internet from your phone every day.
You know, instead of a phone in the Kuiper
system, we have a customer terminal
on your roof or somewhere with a view of the sky.
And it connects wirelessly not to
a cell tower somewhere nearby, like in
the parking lot,
but to one of our satellites in low Earth orbit
about 600 kilometers above the Earth.
You can't run a fiber optic cable up there, so
instead we have to build another wireless link,
our gateway link, to connect our satellites
to our ground gateway antennas,
which are in hundreds of locations all over the world.
Once we're back down on the ground, we can do like
normal things. We can connect our ground gateways
to fiber optics and from there to
our
to our network core and then to the internet
or to your private networks.
And by building the wireless links
ourselves
and by building the ground network
using AWS Edge sites and
AWS Direct Connect,
we're building the fastest, most secure
space-based network in the world.
So
When we started on this a few years ago,
You know,
We have to solve 5 impossible problems, so we have to
start somewhere.
And where we started was by building,
uh, our satellite.
This is not something you just like go buy a satellite
that does 100 gigabit per second,
you know, uh, 100 gigabit per second
communication, low Earth orbit,
and you can build build thousands of them. We
had to build this from the ground up. This is all,
all our technology.
And the way you start with something like
this is we're going to reuse as much as
we can even though we are building from the ground
up. And so we built with a lot
of K
KO's commodity off the shelf
parts.
And if you look at our satellite,
it's kind of like a data center rack
that we launched into space.
You know, it has a commodity Ethernet switch,
and it has a bunch of line cards to run our network,
and they run Linux, and we do IP networking
all throughout the satellite. It's just kind of like a
big, you know, big rack in space.
Our flight computers connected to the switch,
all the line cards.
But you know it's also a little bit like
another thing which is it's like launching a car into
space. It has a canvas like your car does,
which is a like a terrestrial, normal
terrestrial thing
that in your car connects
your computer to all of the sensors
and actuators in your car.
And on our satellite we do kind of the same thing.
Our flight computer connects through a canvas
to some really interesting space devices like
star trackers and reaction wheels
and our propulsion unit
and a torque rod,
and um and with those devices
we can sense where we are in space
and we can control
the attitude of our satellite and we
can propel it.
And you know, on those, though they are interesting
space devices, we again build them on like
normal terrestrial automotive SOCs
like a Cyprus SOC.
And all those
and for the most part, our custom hardware
that runs in the data center rack in
space, those use also
terrestrial SOCs like a Xylynx
versus SOC.
But you know you can't, you can't just buy all the
parts for this,
you know, uh, the part you can't buy in
particular is the RF modem
that is the, the heart of the Kuiper
network. We had to build that ourselves. That's
a custom ASIC.
We built it from scratch.
Even when you're building an ASIC from scratch, you don't
start from scratch.
You build a with a lot of other people's IP
you use
arm instruction set, and that's what we did.
So we built that from the ground up.
Using reusable components, and we had to
spend years like optimizing our code,
optimizing that chip, multiple revisions.
That was definitely the hard part. That's what we wanted to
focus on.
But it turns out no one actually cares
if we built the satellite.
What everyone cares about is actually does
it work in space. Like our biggest
responsibility in Kuiper is not actually
to get a communications
network working. It's to not screw up
low Earth orbit. We take that
space responsibility really seriously.
If we mess it up, like our kids will be cursing
us when they're our age.
So the thing that we have to do
that's most important to building Kuiper.
Is that we have to figure out how to iterate
and test
space things before we're in space.
And you know, space is a really interesting environment.
It's like hot and then cold. It's
dark and then bright,
and it really matters that it's dark and bright
because we get our power from the sun.
So we have to test
hundreds and then thousands and then actually millions
of combinations of how our satellite's
going to be in space.
And this is something AWS can help us with.
So we do a lot of simulation.
We stimulate all these combinations, both normal
things that we want to have happen
like flying and
abnormal things like getting reset
by radiation at just the wrong time.
We test all these things.
And how do we do it?
Well, you know, we basically do it by building a
physics-based game engine
and putting our satellite in it, putting
a model of our satellite, and probably everyone,
you know, everyone's done this, right?
So you have to build like a big game
engine loop in which you have like a really precise
physical model of everything you want to simulate.
And so we, we have a very precise
physical model of our satellite, for example,
like how does it respond to torque,
uh, you know, how big is it, how much does it weigh,
what is its inertia look like, center,
uh, center of mass, all these physical properties.
We put this in the simulation.
And then all those interesting space devices I
mentioned like reaction wheels that
spin and torque rods that also spin
and propulsion units that
propel us in one direction,
and our sensors. We also have precise
physical models of all of those things.
So then in our simulation,
we wrote this code. It has to be us,
it's our satellite after all.
In our satellite and in our simulation,
we're constantly updating
the position and velocity and rotational
rotational acceleration and angular
velocity of our satellite in
all different dimensions so that we can
just kind of propagate it straightforward.
And then we're also applying forces to it in our
simulation. This is what it does. We're applying
like gravity
and forces produced
by our by our actuators.
And then we're also applying our
controls.
We're applying controls from our flight computer
in that produce these forces, and we're just
updating that loop over and over again, just like
a game engine would.
And we built this. We got it working on like
our laptop or like on one Linux box.
But as I mentioned, we have to simulate like
every combination that we're going to see in space
before we fly,
because we really don't want to crash.
And so this is something that AWS can help us
with. And so we basically
use AWS to scale up our simulation.
So we built, you know, like a serverless
application for spinning up constellation
simulations.
And you use this API gateway and you can
like say,
create a simulation for me. And you
can ask it like, is my simulation
running? And you can say I'm done with my
simulation, kill it.
So that's the API.
And then behind that, we're running a bunch of
asynchronous workflows that like
start up EC2 instances and
wait for AC2 instances, and
tear them down and retry
and load our code, start the simulation, like
this is what the step function workflow does.
And kind of the coolest thing about this
is that, you know, inside there when
we're actually ready to run this,
we can run our actual flight code
on graviton instances because as I mentioned,
we're, you know, like not reinventing
instruction sets or anything
we're using ARM and Graviton
is an ARM-based
platform
and so we can run our unmodified flight code
on bare metal EC2 instances
that run Graviton.
And what's even cooler than that is that
um you know I mentioned that we're using like
standard automotive SOC which uh
often or like always or something
have FPGAs on them and we're using FPG
FPGA's field programmable Gatorades
for the most time sensitive, uh,
time sensitive operations that we do on our
satellite
and those typically are like,
uh, radio like listening to radios
and, uh, sending radio signals generating
RF. Uh, or
a time or packet processing at gigabits
per second,
and we can run that FPGA on the,
um, our FPGA code on the FPGA
of bare metal instances with FPGAs
so we basically can run the satellite
pretty much unmodified.
On bare metal instances.
So this
enables us
to scale up our testing
to where we need it to be to launch the Kuiper
satellite.
We did this before we launched our protoflight satellites,
you know, a couple of years ago, as you might have heard, and
once we launched, um,
we found that, yeah, it really
worked pretty much exactly the same way.
It was like almost indistinguishable. It
was, uh, pretty spooky that day. Like we were happy,
of course that's what we wanted to have happen, but
we always worried, and it turned out to be unfounded.
It totally worked. So
you know this is the first problem the
first problem we had to solve, and AWS helped
us scale up.
OK, so
But it's not enough to just like have a satellite
that hangs out in orbit and doesn't crash,
uh, you know what you really have to be able to do is
you have to be able to control that satellite. Like again
we take space safety really seriously. It's
like way more important than actually serving
customers.
You know, if we screw this up, we don't get to serve customers,
so we have to be able to talk to our satellites
like all the time.
We have to talk to thousands thousands
up to 1,000s,
but right now like hundreds of satellites,
and uh we have to be able to monitor them.
We have to know what their current state is and we
have to be able to command them like please steer
around this thing that you might otherwise run into,
uh, so it's really important that we always be
able to know where they are and
always be able to command them.
And we don't mean always like in the next
second we mean always like,
you know, if you can't talk to your satellite for
after 4 hours, you have a serious
problem because, you know, after 8 hours
you might kind of hit something.
So we just always have to be able to talk
to our satellite.
Maybe hardware is failing, doesn't matter, you
have to talk to it.
Uh, you know, maybe it's spinning in space
and it doesn't know which way is up or which way is down,
it doesn't matter. You have to be able to talk to it,
so we have to build
kind of from the ground up,
not like a normal IOT
system. hello.
Not like a normal IoT system that you connect
to the cloud,
but something
kind of like it.
Uh, you know, as I mentioned,
uh, Space IoT,
you know, we're.
Uh, yeah,
we have to always be able to talk, OK, and um.
Because Because,
uh, we have to always be able to
talk, we optimize our management
network, our device cloud for space
IOT,
not for a high throughput or not for
high availability,
but, uh,
but for
eventually being able to talk, and
the inevitable outcome of
this is that we end up with low throughput
because we're just optimized for
being able to talk in any in any context.
So we have to talk to our whole constellation
and monitor it and control it
with actually like really pretty low throughput.
And what this means is
That we are constantly
working with,
we're constantly optimizing.
Which satellites we're gonna talk to when because
every second of radio time is
uh really
important we have to make the most effective
use of it,
so we're optimizing this
and um
in order to optimize
which satellites we talk to when and
which telemetry we're gonna get from them and which commands
we're gonna send when
we have to kind of know.
What is where they will be at any given time
and whether we will need to send them a command
like it is time to steer
uh and what we also need to know
whether we will be able to talk to them successfully
because there could be RF interference or other satellites
around or something like that.
So in the space internet of things,
we're constantly communicating based on
predicted state.
And to know and to know that we
have to create a precise
precise model of every object in low Earth
orbit, where it is right now and
where it will be in basically every
like 5 2nd interval
from now until we need to stop planning, which
is typically several days from now.
And there's tens of thousands of objects in low
Earth orbit,
and so that's many,
many, many things, uh, to have
in memory at one time.
And so what we do is,
uh,
I should mention,
you know, people have known for kind of a long time,
uh, how to propagate
the state of an object in low Earth orbit, you
know, forward in time pretty much
as far as you want,
you know, if you know that an object is here with a position
and a velocity, you will definitely
be able to predict
pretty precisely where it will be in several
days or, you know, even in several
months, uh, but what we need
to be able to do is to be able to query that
model. To understand
where
our satellite is in relation to our ground gateways.
At any time in the future so that we can
optimize our communication.
So we built a service for this,
and the cool thing about it is that
it's basically a normal serverless
serverless application. And so the way we do this is
we run that model and we create
a complete
model of where all the objects in the sky will
be for several days,
and then we stick that all into uh
into an index.
And then
We can query the index anytime we
need to know what is in view
of a ground gateway or what ground
gateways we can talk to from a satellite.
And so we knew the model,
we, we could run the model,
but when we needed to scale up the model,
and we
used AWS technology that you all can use
also, uh, to scale this up.
So Anyway,
the purpose of the constellation is not just to be a
constellation that is safe in space, it's to serve customers
and to provide internet access to the world.
So,
let's
do a brief overview of how does the Kuiper
constellation work.
You know, I mentioned that we have some satellites
in low Earth orbit and we're gonna have about 3200
of them and um.
They communicate wirelessly to our ground
gateways on Earth.
If we get data up to a satellite
from your house,
we're going to have to get it back down to the Earth because that's where the
internet is
today. And um yeah, so
we have ground gateways.
And the internet is not.
It's not by our ground gateways. Our ground
gateways are more or less like required to be
in faraway places away from
people, uh,
like in,
you know, yeah, like out in the middle of nowhere
and, uh, yeah, like a wheat field.
So the internet is not exactly there,
so um.
We, the edge of our network
is a point of presence. It's a network point of presence
that adapts between our internal Kuiper
protocols, which are optimized for space
communication and, uh, fast
changing networks.
We have to adapt between those protocols and like
normal internet protocols, BGP, IP,
that kind of thing.
And that's what we do at our Kuiper point of presence.
So we connect all of our ground infrastructure
using standard fiber optics
and um.
And in particular we connect our ground gateways
to the nearest AWS Direct Connect
location. Because once we're at the AWS Direct
Connect location, you know, those are,
those are at, those are paired with
internet providers like right there.
They have really good internet access, and there are hundreds
of them all over the world.
So But
what you're buying as a customer of Amazon
Leo is you're buying access
to our network through a customer terminal on
your roof.
And you're buying access to a
radio,
a radio network in which we're using radio
frequency spectrum.
About 1.5 gigahertz of spectrum in
the KA band.
Uh, to communicate from our satellites
to the customer terminal and back again.
And then we have a separate radio
frequency
that
we use to talk between our satellites and our ground
gateways.
And um.
Leo's
Low Earth orbit
is.
If you're in low Earth orbit, you're basically moving at
17,000 miles an hour.
Uh, and what that means is you're going to pass over
any spot on the ground in like a few minutes,
like in about 3 minutes or less.
And what that means for a customer
terminal or any spot on the ground
to which we're providing service
is that we're switching which
satellite is providing service to that spot
about every 30 or 40 seconds, maybe
up to 3 minutes, but 30 to 40 seconds.
So we designed the whole network around that
handoff,
around making that handoff and making it smooth.
And our customer terminal basically like
stops transmitting to one satellite or receiving
from it and then starts receiving
from the next one.
And this is called handoff.
Now, If you
imagine that we have, yeah, so I have just
told you that we're basically using radio frequency communication
and we're doing this handoff, we're doing hands off
on the ground gateway as well,
so we're the network is constantly
changing. And so you may imagine
that uh some of these fail. Yes, some
of these do fail, and so we're constantly
uh planning for redundancy and failover
if any of these links fail.
So not only do we plan primary links
between our satellites and customer terminals, we also
plan backup links between our satellites
and customer terminals
and satellites and ground gateways.
So we're providing
service to the world, to every spot on the Earth,
and we have satellites that can talk,
that can provide service to
many spots on the ground below them,
and they require a connection to
hundreds of ground gateway to one of hundreds
of ground gateways
that are on the surface of the Earth.
So you can see that our network, in
our network we have.
Millions of combinations of
how we can provide service at any given time.
And this is a massive optimization problem
because we're not just trying to, we're not just trying
to connect our network,
we're trying to optimize our network we're
trying to provide the fastest service to every
spot where customers are
using just the right amount of our
radio frequency so that we're balancing
service between all the different cells in our network.
We just have to simplify this. Like customer
terminals are coming and going like just as
customers register for our service and
turn on their satellite.
So we have to simplify and the first way that we simplify
is that we don't try to
individually plan every customer terminal.
We provide access to cells on the ground.
We provide access to, uh, we provide
service to hexagons on the ground because hexagons
are the bestagons,
and this helps us simplify the
network down to just providing access to 1.6
million spots on the ground.
But it's still 1.6 million combinations, and we
still have all those satellites and ground station
combinations.
But it's even worse
because all those customer terminals have
different
uh quality of service commitments
in Kuiper we're not just providing best effort
like hey we have a bunch of
you paid us now we will give you whatever
service we can come up with.
We're offering quality of service
to enterprise customers who
pay for like 100 megabits per second.
We will give you 100 megabits per second.
So that means that when we plan our network, we have
to plan
with visibility into all the demand
and all the cells on the ground.
We can do this, like we can,
we can point our radio frequency.
At any spot on the ground we can choose
how much radio frequency to give to any spot
on the ground.
We can change where we're allocating
that radio frequency
very quickly, many times a second,
and so we have the, we have the knobs
in our physical layer network
to optimize this problem, but as you see
it gets even more complicated when we add,
uh, quality of service commitments.
But beyond quality of service.
Many factors in the environment also affect
what service we can provide, whether,
uh, whether provi uh, whether,
uh, the angle at which the satellite is in relation
to the ground spot,
how far away the satellite is from the
ground the ground gateway itself,
all these factors affect
what service we can provide to any spot on
the ground. So this is this, oh, and
the customer demand is changing like
on a minute by minute basis just kind of like a
normal di diurnal diurnal trend
or uh.
Yeah, or there might be a World Cup
or some other interesting event right now,
and all of these affect demand and where we
should allocate our radio frequency
on the ground.
This is a super data intensive, uh, data
intensive process to compute the
right plan for our network at any time.
So
One thing about this is that we are not the first
ones to
To build a wireless network that uh
involves beam pointing,
so there are well known algorithms for
allocating radio resources to spots
and uh some of them use like mixed image or
linear programming and generally speaking like
there are uh
there are algorithms for this, but when we add all of
these factors into them, then we have to,
uh, then it's just our algorithm for
for our network.
And um.
So we built this algorithm, but, and we
can run it
and we can run it for like the continental United States
and you know we can run it for the world,
but when we wanna scale it up and we want to
incorporate all the real-time data
that we need about the world, about our customers,
and about, uh, the current
state of the network,
this is when we, uh, when we use
AWS
and the way we use AWS is to
manage our data.
We manage all of our subscriber data and
kind of slow moving data in Sage Maker
Studio. And all of our fast
moving data like the current state of the network,
the current state of customer demand,
this comes into our,
our network planning system
through managed Kafka.
And then we run this big distributed computation
that I mentioned
on Fargate instances.
Once we have a global plan for our network,
we push it out to every node at the same time,
and the way we do that is that we have an
active connection
through a network load balancer with every node on the
network, and so we can push it
out using web sockets.
So AWS didn't solve the network
planning problem, but it enabled us to scale
up our solution to the network,
the network planning problem
and not have to reinvent data architectures
from scratch.
So the cool thing about low Earth orbit
is, uh, it's like really close by.
You know, it's only like 2 to 4 milliseconds
away from any, you know, any
spot that we're serving on the ground.
And
another cool thing about it
is that the speed of light is faster in a vacuum
than it is in fiber on the ground. So
you know if we're going 600 kilometers up
into space,
that's actually a lot faster than going 600 kilometers
in a fiber on the ground.
And so, you know, after we built this really
cool network,
it would be kind of a shame if
network latency were dominated by like fiber
on the ground.
We turned like 8 milliseconds
into like 100 milliseconds by having the
wrong ground network.
Um, which we could do because.
Yeah, because our ground gateways
are in a lot of different places.
Um
And so, but what we do instead
is that we've built a huge ground
network, hundreds of sites all over the world,
and we've connected them using redundant fiber
paths to the nearest AWS Direct Connect
locations, and we host the edge of our
network, the, the point of presence that I mentioned
earlier, in AWS Edge sites.
And then from there it's we're right
out to the internet from it uh from AWS
edge sites.
And when we need to get to your workload
in
EC2 or yeah your workload in EC2 or S3,
Gary's gonna tell us about the APIs we provide
to enable that,
but that also, uh, goes over
AWS's,
uh, AWS's direct connect network
which, and that's been AWS has been optimizing
that for years.
You know,
Probably everyone is here. Everyone here has been affected
by a fiber optic fiber,
fiber cut at some point.
Like, oh, I thought I had great internet
access, and suddenly it's gone and it turns out
that uh someone with a backhoe
did just the wrong thing at just the wrong time.
And um
when we're talking about ground gateways all
over the place and like farms and fields,
we kind of expect that
from time to time, yes, there will be fiber cuts,
but what's cool about the Kuiper network is
that we have a second backbone
for our network and that's our backbone in space.
And uh we basically have fiber
optics without the fiber. We have just the laser
part in space.
And so instead of going over fiber on the
ground, we can use our optical optical
lasers in space to transmit data
not to just the nearest ground gateway to
the satellite,
but to a different ground gateway through
another satellite.
And uh you know, as you can see,
this is not,
you know, there's no supermarket here.
OK, Um,
yeah, and, uh,
as I mentioned,
we have our ground gateways, you know, all
over the world and hundreds of sites, and they're connected
to AWS's edge sites which
there are hundreds of,
and from there they're connected to the Internet and to AWS
regions, um, everywhere.
So I just told you about how we're building this
really fast space-based network
involving a couple of hops of radio frequency.
Thousands of kilometers of fiber and it's
it's spread all over the world
and so you should
kind of wonder
if we're taking really good care of your
data security and we are.
Data security is built into the lowest layer
of the Kuiper network.
Our custom chip that I mentioned at the
beginning of the talk that runs our network that
generates that radio frequency communication,
our modem,
it also can do encryption and decryption
at gigabits per second.
And uh it has a hardware security module
that keeps the keys for that uh
for that
um private and it's tamper
resistant and we've tested it.
Definitely works.
Uh, and the other end of that encrypted connection
is all the way at the edge of our
network in the pop that I mentioned.
And so it's doing encryption and decryption at gig
gigabits per second.
For all the customer terminals that it's connected
to. And
you know if you built like uh
you know
everyone here has built a secure service and
you know it's really easy to get the encryption part
wrong but then of course it's really easy
to get the
access to keys and identity management part
wrong also
uh but by building on
the same cryptographic primitives
that you all use and that other AWS
customers use
we can
know a few things.
One is that we're using.
Kind of
known standard implementations of cryptographic
algogorithms through like AWSLC
and AWS
using AWSLC
and we're also
keeping really good track of our keys.
Our keys are stored in AWS
KMS,
and they never leave our, we never
touch them in our data plane code because
they go from AWS KMS into nitro
enclaves.
We only get like a short-lived time
drive key
to use in our data plane code for fast encryption
at gigabits per second.
And you know we protect access to all those keys
using IAM just like you would
so that only the services that should have access
to our keys do have access to our keys.
Another cool thing about this is that when
we're sending your data over the Direct
Connect network,
uh, we're also using it's Maxsec on the ground,
so, you know, first.
If someone were to intercept our radio
radio,
they would not see your data. They won't see IP
addresses. They won't see TLS headers. They'll
see encapsulated, fully encrypted data,
and they will not see your data.
But then if they go find our fiber they won't
even see our data they'll see, you know, random
encryptable bits
protected by Maxec.
So our network is and is
secure in transit from customer
terminal to the edge of our network
and uh we
and that is enabled by the same cryptographic
primitives that you all use today.
So
Those are some of the key problems that we solved
in Amazon Leo, to enable us to
get into space and to constantly
communicate with our satellites,
and then to plan our network.
And to optimize it to give great
quality of service to all the spots on the ground that
we're serving.
And then also to secure communication
and to scale our network
to global scale.
So now Gary's gonna tell us about how you
can use that network
from your AWS, uh, from your AWS
network. uh, thanks Gary.
Thanks, Andy.
That was super cool.
If you didn't get the data points,
17,000
MPH these things are moving at.
Right, they're doing handoffs about every
30 seconds.
There was one there.
There's one, another one.
This is amazing technology that we're building.
Andy walked us through
how they used AWS to build
these solutions for Amazon Leo.
Now, is anyone here in the audience planning to
build a low Earth orbit system? Anyone?
Really,
good for you.
How about the rest of you? I bet you're hoping to use
an existing low Earth orbit system like Amazon
Leo to improve your systems, right?
OK, great, a few hands.
Well, that's what we wanna talk about.
Leo can be used for multiple different use cases.
It could be used as internet connectivity
in remote areas,
right? That's a kind of a personal use
case. But more interestingly,
probably for customers of AWS like yourselves,
are the industrial use cases.
Or you may have equipment that runs
in a far off place of the world,
or you may have equipment that runs
off the ground and
actually in the middle of the ocean,
somewhere where bringing fiber or connectivity
is either difficult,
expensive, or inconsistent.
Leo can help us with all these use cases.
So Leo is a networking capability
from your AWS perspective.
So let's look at how we can do
connect to your account from a networking side.
We're going to walk through just a first as a
really simple customer internet use case example.
You're a customer
You're somewhere else remote.
You want to get to the public internet.
Well, you connect to your customer terminal,
your antenna, your Leo antenna.
The Leo antenna
Connects up to the LEO satellite up in the sky,
right, around 600 kilometers
in the sky, I believe the number was.
That satellite connects down to a ground
station. From the ground
station to a pop and out to the internet.
Pretty simple use case.
Doesn't utilize AWS.
From your account's perspective.
However, what if we did want to integrate it with our account?
Well, what can we do then?
Leo has this concept called the customer
virtual network.
And what that customer virtual network does
is it creates a virtual device.
This virtual network interface.
The VNI,
which is a representation.
A virtual representation of
your Leo satellite dish.
Your antenna.
Every antenna
basically has a 1 to 1 connection
with a virtual network interface.
That virtual network interface provides
IP addresses,
provides DNS,
and provides some configuration
to what your antenna can do.
And you may have different use cases for different
antennas.
Maybe you have one use case that only
allows for private
internet access, meaning it only allows access to your
corporate network. You might have another antenna that
allows public internet access.
And it's controlled at the
antenna using the customer virtual
network. Now
if we look a little bit further,
there's another component
that we have in here.
There's a component called the virtual
network gateway.
With that gateway.
We can now control what our network or what
our antenna can do.
We've got 3 different gateway opportunities.
One, connect us right to the internet, again,
more of a consumer use case.
The second
We'll connect you directly to AWS
direct to AWS D2A.
We like using number acronyms at AWS, so
that's the D2A 1.
The 3rd 1 is a private network interconnect,
a PI.
So whereas the second one there, the D2A,
will connect to your
AWS VPC.
The 3rd 1 there will connect to your
private network through some kind of meet me
point, network to network connectivity.
Here's what it would look like and why you might want
to use it.
So let's say you have a Leo
network. You've got an antenna.
But you've got a corporate data center,
and in that corporate data center you have some private
infrastructure. You've got some servers,
some storage, some databases,
but you need to be able to access it remotely.
Through the private network interface, you
can connect your Leo antenna
to your private data center.
Again, this is part of what Leo does. This
isn't an AWS
service that you would do in your account.
But now let's assume that you did want to do something
in your account.
You wanted to access services that were within
your VPC.
Well, in this case, if we use the direct to
AWS connection, we could do that.
Leo connects to your VPC
and services that are within your VPC, let's
say EC2 or Sagemaker, are
now accessible from the Leo antenna.
But what about services that aren't in your VPC?
There are managed services that AWS
has.
Well, through a private link you can access those
as well.
So what we've got here now is services
that you're managing in your VPC,
your business use case now
accessible anywhere in the globe.
With a Leo antenna.
Now we want to connect this to your
AWS account.
And one thing I want to highlight
is that Leo
is not an AWS service.
Leo is a service that comes from Amazon, from
the Amazon Leo team. It is not
an AWS service. It is not a resource
in your AWS account.
But we want you to have a seamless interface.
We want you to have an experience that
looks as if
you are building with native resources.
One of the ways we do that is to give Leo some permission
in your account.
And we do that through a new temporary
delegation process
from IAM. This is a new service that was
announced just a few days ago.
And with that delegation,
the Leo system has access to your
AWS account.
And it uses that access
in order to
Provide you with telemetry of what's
happening in the Leo service
within your AWS account.
So as the service runs,
telemetry information is populated into
your AWS account.
In a cloud watch, cloud trail, etc.
So again,
Leo is not an AWS service,
but We are working in such a way
that it will appear like an AWS
service in your account,
meaning that you can collect the telemetry,
you can set up the triggers, you can act on
events, and you can take action if something goes
wrong. Now
let's look at some
D2A direct to AWS Leo
examples.
Again, we're builders here, we want to figure
out what we're going to build, how we're going to build it.
We've got a couple of examples here that we think
may align with hopefully some of you here in the
crowd. What
if you're running a wind farm?
And you're running a wind farm and you've got a wind farm
somewhere out in the ocean.
A lot of wind in the ocean.
So you put a wind farm there,
not a lot of network connectivity in the ocean, unfortunate
part. But we want to
run a wind farm.
And we want to make sure that we are optimizing our wind
farm for health.
Predictive maintenance,
all those good things.
There are some patterns that we know
have been utilized often in
AWS to monitor something like a
wind farm.
IoTre AWS IOTorre
is a common way to do that.
Collects telemetry
from your wind farm.
Receives that telemetry,
stores the data in time streams so you know what's
happening over time.
Maybe you're visualizing it with grafana.
But you may also have a trigger that
occurs when anomalies may be detected
from your wind farm.
And those anomalies may be processed
within something like EKS.
Or either one.
To understand whether or not this anomaly actually
needs us to take action.
And if we do need to take action,
maybe we have an event that then send
signals back to our wind farm to slow
down or to halt,
maybe opens up a work order to have a
technician get on a boat and get out there
to fix the thing.
But again, this wind farm is out in the middle of the ocean.
No fiber out there
No internet connectivity.
Well, this is where
Leo comes in.
If we utilize the antenna
together with our remote wind farm
and we utilize the.
Direct to AWS connectivity,
we can now bridge this wind farm in the middle of
the ocean,
back to the exact same patterns that we would have
to build
digital twins and monitor
our wind farms in the cloud.
There's a link there at the top. There are in the next couple
of slides as well
for references to some of these architectures.
Let's look at another example,
egress traffic inspection.
I think we all know that ingress
traffic, traffic coming into your network,
everyone puts up a firewall, right? We want to make
sure none of the traffic coming into us.
We need to block any nefarious traffic,
right, so we have a firewall.
But what's becoming even more common.
Is that teams want to have
ingress or egress verification,
meaning I don't want data leaving my system
because my data is proprietary to me.
I don't want to be leaking data to the outside world.
So I may have egress traffic inspection.
Very common pattern,
something we do in the cloud, maybe using
something like AOS network firewall.
But what if I'm operating remotely somewhere?
I have a remote site,
maybe a mining site. Maybe I'm mining gold,
and I don't want my competitors to know how much gold
I've mined.
But my mining process requires a lot of compute.
Which is great,
and I need to do that on premises.
So what do I do? I use Amazon outposts.
With Amazon AWS outposts, I can have EC2
compute
running in a private subnet on premises.
That's great.
When I need to launch a new container or
I need to launch a new piece of software on
it, I may actually need to have internet
access. Maybe I need to PI install or
maybe I need to yum update something,
right? So I need to have network
access outbound.
But again, I have requirements
from my security team that say
no egress traffic unless it's
inspected.
How am I gonna inspect it?
Well, by connecting my outpost
back to my network
in the cloud, back to my VPC
through Kuiper or through sorry, Amazon
Leo. I
can actually
force all of my traffic coming from
EC2 running in my outpost on
premises
to go through my firewall endpoints that live
in the region
in my VPC.
Out through my
network firewall to check for
allowability, whether it's allowed to get out or not,
and only if it is, will it then egress
to the internet,
right? So I've got security.
This will make sure
that none of my gold mining information.
Gets leaked outside of my network.
Only my PI installs and Yum updates
do, but my gold mining does
not. One
more example
Amazon has a uh a
video division, right, we make movies.
Sometimes we make those movies in very remote
locations. And when we make those
movies, we come out on set with a bunch of
equipment, a bunch of very expensive equipment.
And we need to monitor that site.
is secure
and so we need to put up security cameras in
that remote location.
But it's remote. Again, remote means
hard to get network access, hard to get
fiber,
yet we need to do this.
And I've got administrators in system opps
that need to watch those cameras to make sure
that nothing gets stolen, nothing gets interfered
with. Well, a
common way we would do this in the cloud
is we would use something like IoT Core,
Kinesis video streams to stream those
videos from the,
from the cameras.
We would create some
review process using something like lambda
and open search. Maybe we even create some
dashboard that can be accessed by our remote
by our administrators so that they can see the
cameras.
Right, again,
common pattern to deal with cameras
in the cloud.
Problem is our cameras are far remote.
There are no connecting, no connectivity.
Well here once again, even in this pattern, Leo
can help us out.
Using a Leo antenna
connection with a D2A.
D2A connection,
we go through a VPC,
we go through a private link.
We're now able to connect this entire
infrastructure running in the cloud with
cameras that are
in a remote location on site
watching our trucks, our cameras,
our our our film cameras, our crew
to make sure everyone is safe in this remote
location while they're filming the next episode of
your favorite show.
And So
again This is your AWS
accounts. These are your VPCs.
You are just getting connected to your remote
access or getting remote accessed via
Leo. All
right, quick recap, so we're
coming up on time.
We talked about how Amazon Leo
utilized the same AWS resources
to build out their Leo service that you have
access to. No
special treatment just because we're all Amazonians.
Or maybe a little special treatment, but.
Um, no special treatment when it comes from an AWS
resource perspective. They have access to the same
resources that you do.
So for the gentleman over there who is building a low Earth
orbit system, you've got
all the, you've got all the tools that your hand in your
hands that you need.
The next thing we talked about, we looked at some examples,
is how in your
AWS accounts, in your VPCs,
you can utilize Leo to extend
the extend your networks to the edge,
basically anywhere around the globe.
What we're really curious
to know,
and we had a couple of examples of how we think
people can use Leo,
but we're really curious to know how you're gonna use
Leo. How you, when
taking Leo into your AWS account,
what are you going to do with it?
Maybe you'll tell us.
Hopefully you will.
Hopefully you'll get a chance to, cos I'm really curious
how Leo is gonna help you out.
If you'd like to learn more about Leo as
a as a service, Amazon Leo,
that link will take you to a page with
more information.
We'll give you the opportunity to sign up
for beta or to track availability,
general availability of the service.
And with that, I'd like to thank everyone for their
time today.
Um, I promise you we were more interesting than
than Werner.
I can't promise you that. I hope we were more
interesting than Werner.
Um, thank you all very much. Uh, enjoy
the rest of your reinvent.